- Ugh, straight white
men, am I right?
- But you're--
- Your sista.
- No.
- Stop!
You've participated
in a trolling cliche.
One degree of separation.
You're a straight white woman,
and that makes
you uncomfortable,
because you're just
a woe away from being
a straight white man.
You're only one rung down
on the privilege pyramid,
so what do you do?
Do you go to Bangladesh
to help orphans?
Do you give all your
money to the NAACP?
No, of course not.
You log on and start talking
shit about straight white men
hoping that all the people
of color in the world
will scream, "We knew you
were one of the good ones,"
but you're not.
You're one of the annoying
ones, and I'm the right guy
to tell you that, 'cause
I'm a straight white man.
(hip hop music)